I'm listening to your beautiful accent.
But, is it true that the
late Great John Singleton,
that he had you come out here
to do something with the role?
- [Damson] That's true.
By audition number eight,
Singleton took me to South-Central,
opened the car door and
said, if you survive,
you've got the role.
(audience laughs)
(Damson laughs)
And it really was an experience.
You know, I was walking
around South Central.
I had to stay in character,
so I wasn't allowed to be British.
And I said to his mother,
"Oh, how lovely your hair looks today.
I'm just gonna go and, you know, put some,
put this in a bin."
And she goes, "John! He
ain't from here, huh?"
- [Drew] Yeah. (laughs)
- Nearly lost the part.
But hey, six seasons later.
Here we are.
(audience applause)
- Six seasons later.
And this is the final season, right?
- Yeah.
- And I didn't know this.
Is this true?
That you are friends
with Jay-Z and Beyonce?
(Damson laughs)
(audience applause)
- Yeah, I...
I've been 'round them many times. Yes.
- [Drew] Oh, my God.
What are they like?
Because like, they're very
embracing of you, right?
- [Damson] Yeah.
- Like, he's like paternal,
basically, with you a bit.
- Yeah, I- I'll be in Miami,
it's late, and I'll call
them up and I'll be like,
"Hey, I can't get a
reservation at Carbone.
(laughter)
And then he went, "Damn, see.
You gotta win a couple more Emmys
before you can call me at 11:30."
(laughter)
(audience applause)
But they're the sweetest.
We connected in many ways.
But the Super Bowl was
really great because,
it was like the first time
I kind of connected with,
with B, and you know, I
had just walked for Prada,
which was huge. Such a huge moment for me.
- [Drew] And aren't you wearing Prada now?
- [Damson] I am.
(audience whoops)
(audience applause)
- And it's looking real good.
- I need a new campaign.
Thank you for that plug.
(laughter)
- And I know that you
have a close connection
with your sister, is it? I believe?
- (laughs) Yes.
- [Drew] And you have a special
connection with tuxedos?
- Yes.
- And, is it true that your sister
did something with you in a tuxedo?
(Damson laughs)
- So, when I was a kid, right?
Like 4, 5, 6 years old,
my mother would always
dress me in these tuxedos
for my birthday.
- The cutest.
- The cutest, yes,
but what was borderline
insane, was my sister,
she would make me marry her doll, Wendy.
Yes.
(audience laughs)
- [Drew] Well, in...
- I got married many times.
- In honor of your sister,
would you ever consider marrying a doll
in a tuxedo, right now?
(Drew chuckles)
(audience whoops)
(Damson chuckles nervously)
- Oh, my God.
- [Drew] Okay. So...
(audience cheers)
So, Damson...
I was just wondering.
I know you're in Prada.
- Oh, my Lord.
- By the way, my daughter is in crutches,
so I'm actually really good
at getting people dressed.
(audience laughs)
So...
- What is happening right now?
- I know.
This is what we do on this show.
We're silly and we like to have fun.
And what also is a special connection
to this particular doll?
Her name is Courtney but I call
her (high pitched) Courtney,
because when we lo... Oh, hello?
(audience whoops)
- Oh, my God. You're making me blush.
Wow. Look at this.
(audience applause)
What is...
(Damson laughs)
(audience cheers)
- So...
Damson, when we launched our show,
we launched in the pandemic and
nobody could come on the show.
- Oh, wow.
- And so we didn't have an audience.
We didn't have guests.
And I would talk to Courtney a lot.
(audience laugh)
And I was wondering if
you would marry her.
- Sure, Courtney.
(Drew laughs)
- Okay. So what would your sister do?
Would it be like,
"Damson, would you take the Courtney,
to be your lawfully wedded wife?"
- I do!
(laughter)
- And Courtney,
would you take the dapper,
gentlemanly, talented,
wonderful Damson, to be your
lawfully wedded husband,
of which you'd be so lucky?
- Will you, Courtney?
- Oh, there's a ring.
You have a ring!
Oh, my God.
(audience applause)
Damson Idris.
The sixth and final season of Snowfall,
is out now on FX.
We'll be right back.
(theme music)
(audience applause)
(theme music continues)